Dr Godfrey cited one of Adventist
favorite proof texts earlier from Mark 2
that uh the Sabbath was made for man not
angels and it's not Eternal it was
[Music]
made what's up y'all so I'm going to
react to a video that someone sent us
that was too funny not to respond to
it's of an Adventist whose channel name
is bro Lawrence or brother Lawrence he's
reacting to some statements on the
Sabbath from W Robert Godfrey who I
happened to to love I actually have his
teaching set on DVD on the Shelf next to
me Dr Godfrey is a Reformed Presbyterian
pastor and the former president of
Westminster Seminary so let's see what
this Adventist has to say to him when
asked a question about the Sabbath this
is what the Sunday keeping professor
said let's listen so Dr Godfrey uh you
referenced uh the Christian Sabbath uh
earlier what is what is the most
important things that Christians should
understand about Sabbath
well it's it's interesting to me as a
church historian that um almost all
Protestants in America through the 17th
18th 19th well into the 20th century
regarded Sunday as a Christian Sabbath
and then somewhere around the
1960s um there there were many
Evangelical voices raised to say there
really is no connection between Sunday
and the fourth Commandment of the Old
Testament and that becomes one of the
critical theological issues is there or
is there not a connection between the
fourth Commandment of the Ten
Commandments and um Sunday is Sunday an
arbitrary day that the church has chosen
to worship Christ would we be free in
the New Covenant to worship God on any
day that was convenient convenient to us
and um uh although it will sound a
little self-serving I do have a teaching
series for lioner on that subject um
where I get into more details the the
basic line that I would argue is when it
comes to the fourth Commandment the
critical question is is the Sabbath of
the fourth Commandment simply a mosaic
institution in which one could well
argue it is passed away with so much of
the Mosaic institutions for Israel or is
it a creation
institution in which case in some sense
it continues forever with creation and
my argument would be um one of the most
important things we're taught in Genesis
1 and two is that God not only created
in six days but rested on the seventh
day and blessed the Sabbath for whom did
God bless the Sabbath not for himself
he's blessed and all he does at all
times he blessed the Sabbath for us so
it's a creation Institution is that the
question you
asked why is Jesus called the Lamb of
God this is what Professor Robert
Godfrey had to say when asked a question
about the Sabbath in fact this professor
has been speaking about the Sabbath and
also has been debunking the argument
some Christians use against keeping the
Sabbath uh yes because Dr Godfrey is a
Pres prian such as myself he affirms
what's in the Westminster Confession
it's not some secret hidden thing but he
affirms what's in the Westminster
Confession regarding the Sabbath which
was around hundreds of years before
seventh day adventism was even a thing
I'm not sure why this is so shocking to
so many sdas other than they're just not
keyed in on History um to to be shocked
at something like this is not shocking
and just listen to what he said until
the 1960s this was the normative
understanding amongst Protestants so
there shouldn't be be some shocking
thing that oh look at this pastor he's
talking about Sabbath the ironic thing
about this is that the SDA Pioneers they
stole all of their arguments from the
Sabbath or or for the Sabbath from
people such as Robert Godfrey's
spiritual ancestors my spiritual
ancestors the reformed the Puritans Etc
yet Adventist will claim they were all
wrong universally about the day they
were right about the Sabbath being a
creation ordinance it was made for man
not just the Jews yet they were
supposedly Universal wrong about the day
no that just evidences for us that they
had the Pioneers had no clue what they
were talking about as the first day is
Central to the entire schema of what Dr
Godfrey is putting forth here the Sunday
keeping Christians sometimes think that
there is a connection between the fourth
Commandment and
Sunday but I want to say that there is
no connection between the fourth
Commandment and Sunday because the
fourth Commandments as found in Exodus
chapter 20 was referring to the seventh
day Sabbath or was referring to the
seventh day of the week but not the
first day so he Praises Dr Godfrey in
his arguments Sabbath being a creation
ordinance made for man not just the Jews
Etc yet Dr Godfrey is apparently
confused on the day and has no basis for
that all of the arguments folks that
Adventist try and used to support the
Sabbath were around long before they
were and they were used by first day
sabbatarians in opposition to 7th Day
sabbatarianism again Adventists will
appeal to people like this to say see
they believe like we do and they'll
praise the person there are people in
the comments of this video saying that
pastor's preaching the third Angel's
message bro um no he's not uh but
they'll try and and and appeal to people
like this and get all gidy and think
that it somehow supports adventism but
then they'll try and do the but they
were wrong about the day thing hey
Lawrence I got a question for you do you
think that just maybe just a a thought
here do you think that Dr Godfrey maybe
has a reason for the first day just like
he laid out his reasons for the sa the
Sabbath being
Perpetual what did he appeal to he
appealed to
scripture I understand that it would
require retiring the myth that the pope
changed the Sabbath and there's this big
conspiracy but if you do enough digging
he's mentioned it I mentioned it Dr
godfre in his series on this he explains
the first day in his Sabbath lectures so
you responded to part of that in part
one of this response you need to listen
to the Fuller set of his lectures but
also Lawrence appealed to creation and
the seventh day not realizing that the
seventh excuse me the seventh day of
creation was not man's seventh day it
was Gods based on evening to evening the
seventh day was Man's first day he
started his week in Holy Communion with
God before then going out to fulfill the
command to subdue the Earth through his
labor this becomes tainted then When sin
is enters in and man's rest even becomes
cursed such that now when he works he'll
work by the sweat of his brow before
getting rest the second adom Jesus then
comes and restores what was broken
including the rest of man and reorients
things back to that preall orientation
but also this gentleman in his part one
of this response to Dr Godfrey if he
would have been paying attention he
explains that the Sabbath is a pattern
the seventh day is a pattern Lawrence I
think since you were too enamored with
thinking this Sunday keeping Pastor
affirming the Seventh Day Adventist
Church's position he didn't catch that
Dr Godfrey doesn't believe a 24-hour
rotation around the Sun has some sort of
divin likee characteristic like sdas
have infused into Saturday when Dr
Godfrey says that the Sabbath is is
perpetual as long as there's creation
he's not talking about eternal like you
guys you guys have drawn this out so far
to where you say angels are keeping it
prior to the creation of the Earth in
this whole great controversy prear
origin story you have Angels supposedly
keeping the Sabbath yet Dr Godfrey cited
one of Adventist favorite proof texts
earlier from Mark 2 that uh the Sabbath
was made for man not angels and it's not
Eternal it was made when we enter into
the antip iCal Promised Land eternity
where Christ has entered in ahead of us
into God's rest the Eternal State we're
not going to be keeping a weakly cycle
observing a weekly Sabbath yet again
sdas will point to people like this who
think that what they're saying somehow
validates adventism when no they're not
saying the same thing at all first day
sabbatarians and seventh day
sabbatarians are not arguing the same
thing just on a different day the day is
a part of the ceremonial form of the
command not the substance and the
ceremonial form can change not only can
it it has multiple times in Redemptive
history notice Lawrence cited Exodus 20
and not Deuteronomy 5 in the first
giving of the law in Exodus the Sabbath
is rooted in Creation in the second it's
rooted in Redemption that is a change in
the ceremonial form they were to
remember creation then they were to
remember being led out of bondage of
slavery in Egypt that is a change in the
command it is the ceremonial form
that is what the day is a part of it's
not the substance the substance which
does not change has not changed the
ceremonial form of the command has and
does change multiple times throughout
Redemptive history the day is a memorial
and Adventists do not get this they make
the memorial the substance when the
memorial is a landmark or a marker that
points to the substance which is Jesus
who came and redeemed the creation that
fell making a new creation and he
entered his rest the first day after the
work of redemption was accomplished not
the seventh day that is why the memorial
of the new creation which we are in is
the first day and not the seventh okay
the Bible makes it clear that the
seventh day is the Sabbath and Through
the Bible we have seen that Saturday is
the seventh day so I will say there is
no connection between between the fourth
Commandment and Sunday Lawrence the
seventh day is a pattern which is why if
you had listened more closely in your
first reaction to Dr Godfrey you would
have heard him say this and again
Adventists do not realize that man was
not there on day one two 3 4 Etc the
seventh day was God's seventh day not
man's and there's a reason that God has
remained in that rest since the creation
week it was typological of God in
creation who would come and redeem what
man broke the creation and then God in
the person of Christ would enter into
God's rest the Eternal State ahead of
his people as the second Adam their new
representative before God the father
that's how I can affirm things like
Ephesians 2 which says I'm presently
seated with Christ Jesus in the
heavenlies that's because Jesus is my
representative he went in there ahead of
me that's how I'm seen as righteous as a
Believer is on the merits and basis of
Jesus Christ his perfect death burial
Resurrection his perfect sinless life
Etc that's how I can presently be in
heaven dwelling in Christ but not
physically be there yet but unlike the
rest from Creation in the rest of
redemption God entered his rest the
first day not the seventh hence why the
Sabbath is rooted in both creation and
redemption in the first and second
givings of the law because both of those
pointed to Jesus it's pretty wild that
this guy thinks that what Dr Godfrey is
saying actually supports adventism
because no it doesn't at all and Godfrey
understands New Creation I've heard him
teach on
it now concerning the previous video I
made about this professor's Hest
presentation about the Sabbath there
were some people who wanted to know more
about this professor so Dr Godfrey was a
professor of church history at West
Minister Theological Seminary in
California
USA he taught church history since 1981
and served as the seminary's third
president from 1993 to 2017 he
previously taught at Gorden Conwell
Theological Seminary Stanford University
and West Minister Theological Seminary
in Philadelphia this professor is more
than 65 years old and his understanding
of the Sabbath is different from other
Sunday keeping Christians his
understanding of the Sabbath and
position on the Sabbath is ancient it's
not even unique to the reformed this is
a perfect example of how Adventists will
take a modern move and blanket all of
Christianity with it and then they have
these sort of confused you know sort of
responses Dr Godfrey just explained
earlier that until the 1960s this was
the standard understanding amongst
Protestants and if you go and and read
reformed classical you know Protestant
works on the subject such as Nicholas
bound you'll find it wasn't unique to
them either this was the ancient
Church's position we've looked at this a
number of times on this platform so an
Adventist try and point to this post
1960 Western Christian influence to
Broad brush you know all of Christendom
they really just evidence they have a
really frail understanding of church
history but friends I think he has not
fully understood the doctrine of the
Sabbath because there are some
statements sometimes he make about the
Sabbath that are not in line with the
scriptures when I say the Sabbath I mean
the seventh day Sabbath so you can can
pray for him and ask God to help him
understand the whole truth about the
seventh day
Sabbath my the irony Lawrence I think
you haven't fully quite understood this
like you think that you do because again
in part one you acted as though what Dr
Godfrey was saying somehow supports
adventism it doesn't at all and all the
arguments that you guys use were
borrowed from people like Dr Godfrey
reformed and Puritan Christians that's
why you guys think that he's pared or
preaching the same thing you guys are
when no your Pioneers stole the
arguments of people like Dr Godfrey but
then you try to say well but see they
don't understand the day they have no
biblical basis for the day yes we do the
issue is that you everyone was not in
the dark on this until the SDA Church
came along to Enlighten them yes that
includes uh the day of the the Sabbath
day in the new creation the New Covenant
the root issue is that Adventists do not
understand New Creation but Lawrence
also highlighted another issue here that
aot lot of them end up running into and
that's Sabbath doesn't mean seventh day
it means to cease or to rest seventh day
sabbatarians have a habit of doing this
they always Infuse seventh day into the
word so maybe that explains some of the
confusion here but this was a perfect
example folks to see how sdas bring a
lot of assumptions to this subject
understand that all of their arguments
for the Sabbath yes all of
them all of them were around long before
them they were being used in opposition
7th Day sabari ISM the position that Dr
godfre is putting forth is not unique to
him it's not some Modern thing I mean we
can trace this back 1800 1900 almost
2,000 years at this point so an
Adventist try and point to to post 1960s
minority Christian history to then
blanket all of Christians with it really
just shows us that it's sdas that need
better educated on this subject not
Professor Godfrey uh professor of church
history but anyways if there's a video
you want to see us respond to in like
fashion let us know in the comments Down
Below in the meantime you can go check
out our two-part series uh in response
to Doug Bachelor where we do a much more
comprehensive examination on the subject
of the first day Sabbath the link will
magically appear for that in three two
one